the devil worshipers used to be real
secretive like going down in the
basement thisam gree of Peace welcome to
the de Shan Med your host we got a lot
to talk about Tyrese it's all God right
because you know we should as Believers
we should go the rest of our life trying
to figure out God that should be an
everlasting hunt I just feel like we're
in competition right now because they
are trying to normalize the devil they
are trying to pop the devil is is on the
main stage at award show
and in every video and signs and symbols
just pearly and that's where I began my
journey but I always had a very healthy
respect for Islam because I understand
that to a degree we know there are many
benefits to the use of black seed that's
why I use the black seed by tesque use
promo code the dean show for 15% off
Indonesia and all of this we're going to
get into it with my next
guest
[Applause]
let me ince you to my
face we have one God name Allah
Allah and his final Messengers muhamad
peace be upon him this is our religion
Islam Islam this is the
de I love you the work you're doing when
I was ready to talk about it I
I was explaining how much respect I have
for the faith of
Islam how are
you to everybody out there all the
Believers now what did you say for many
people tuning in they're like we want to
hear what these Muslims have to say but
now we got to take an Arabic class this
is the greeting of Peace we say assalam
the peace upon you and the mercy of God
some would consider you a Bible scholar
because you spent a lot of time and you
got actually your Bible right there I do
what was the greeting of Jesus how would
he say it in Aramaic or in the Hebrew
translate yeah you will find the same
greeting uh even amongst Jews today you
will find Shalom and you will find uh
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him we
love him as the prophet of God we
respect him and he had the same
greetings and you will find him also
praying as those that are interested as
you see muslims praying you will see
Abraham and Moses all using the similar
greetings of peace upon the Believers
and praying in the same way that the
Muslims pray today unpackaged that for
us now for PE some people hearing that
for the first time you said we love
Jesus yes what does that mean we love
Jesus I mean for us how can a Muslim
people are thinking come on now what are
you guys just trying to like you know
win favors with us the Christians what
do you you love Jes he a Muslim now say
we love Jesus that's wonderful to and
explain because for us as Muslims we're
not trying to win favors from anybody we
have God that's enough for us but the
fact of the matter is that in our
religion of Islam we love all the
prophets Abraham Moses David Jesus
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon all
of them you will never see a Muslim
burning pictures of Jesus even though we
don't agree with making pictures of
prophets you will not see a Muslim
burning even the Bible you will not see
a Muslim making disrespectful cartoons
of Jesus peace and blessings be upon him
in fact when non-muslims when when
atheists disrespect Jesus by making
characteres Muslims are the ones that
get upset more than Christians because
we love Jesus we love Moses we love
Abraham we love Muhammad peace and
blessings
be upon all of them just like when we
say the name of our Prophet Muhammad we
say the name of our Prophet Jesus and
say peace and blessings be upon Him
Allah the god the Creator who inspired
the prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon Him is the same Allah that Jesus
peace and blessings be upon him was sent
by with his command and this you can
find in the Bible if you look in the
Bible if you're a Christian you can
follow with me and you can open up
to
John
1249 in the Bible John 12:49 it says for
I according to the Christian Bible this
is the King James Version New King James
Version
1249 in the Bible John 12:49 it says for
I according to the Christian Bible this
is the King James Version New King James
version for I have not spoken on my own
authority according to the Bible Jesus
is saying that I don't speak on my own
authority but the father who sent me
gave me a command John 2017 this is John
12:49 49 John 1249 and we'll continue
into 50 so John if you're watching and
you're Christian open up your Bible take
a look John 12: 4950 for I have not
spoken on my own authority but the
father who sent
me he the father he gave me a command
what I should say and what I should
speak and I know that his command that
of the father is everlasting life
therefore whoever I whatever I speak
just as the father has told me so I
speak now
interestingly when we look at the word
father it's repeated in the Bible many
times the same word and I can show you
some of the Greek later is used for
other than God meaning it's a term of
respect just like the word son people
talk about the the verse in John also
mentioning Jesus being the begotten son
is used for other than Jesus so these
terms are not to show literal
relationships rather there are terms of
endearment right we do not believe as
Muslims that God has a son or a father
or an uncle or a brother or roommate or
any of those kinds of relationship who
was never married you know we believe
God's above all that and that's
something you find in the Bible if you
look in Exodus and this is in the Old
Testament
4:22 this is in Old Testament in your
Bible you can look it up if you're a
Christian then you shall say to Pharaoh
thus says the the Lord Israel is my son
my firstborn so now if this is to be
taken literally that son here means the
physical son then Israel would be the
firstborn of God and he would be the
older brother of Jesus in fact in the
Same Old Testament this is now in 2
Samuel
7134 so 2 Samuel 7
1314 he shall build a house for my name
this is talking about Solomon it's
reference to David about his son Solomon
he said he shall build a house for my
name and I will establish the Throne of
his kingdom forever I will be his father
and he shall be my son now obviously
Solomon is not physically the Son of God
he's the son of David right and here
it's made very clear that son is a term
of endearment this is not a physical
relationship now many Christians may
come back and say well Jesus is called a
begotten son and that's different well
if you're a Christian open up the Psalms
of David The Book of Psalms 2 7 chapter
2 verse 7 again we're not in the New
Testament here in the Book of Psalms
here it says to
David again pre Jesus here peace and
blessings be upon all the prophets I
will declare the decree the Lord has
said to me you are my son today I have
begotten you right now this is here and
you can find tons of others like like uh
one of the duat in the past said there
Sons by the tong in Jeremiah
319 it says for I am a father to Israel
and Ephraim is my firstborn so we would
say
that none of these are physical
relationships rather they are terms of
endearment now many Christians may be
surprised when we say that God above is
the greatest and the rest whether it's
the prophet Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon him or the prophet Jesus peace
and blessings be upon him or the prophet
Abraham peace and blessings be upon him
or the prophet Moses peace and blessings
be upon him are true righteous Servants
of God they are the ones that are sent
by God but the greatest is only the one
God above when we say this Christians
can go to their own Bible in John you
will find Chapter 5 Verse 18 therefore G
the Jews sought all more to kill him
because he not only broke the Sabbath
but he also said the the God was his
father making himself equal with God
this is where the people made this
accusation but in the same chapter now
if you go further down it will say that
Jesus said to them I can of myself do
nothing as I hear I judge my judgment is
righteous because I do not seek my own
he's clarifying to them I'm not clar I'm
not putting myself at the place of God
Jesus is saying my righteous my judgment
is that of God because I do not seek my
own but my own will but the will of the
father who sent me so again Jesus is
saying that I'm not when you're making
these accusations against me and this is
interesting because many Christians
claim the same today that Jesus said he
was God when he never did in the entire
Bible you'll never find anywhere that
Jesus clearly says I'm God and sometimes
people take the verse about I am and
we'll discuss that but here he makes it
very clear he says I do not seek my my
my own will but the will of the father
who sent me if and this is verse 31 now
if I bear witness of myself my witness
is not
true you know this this is in the Bible
so we say Jesus was sent by God by the
Creator as a prophet as somebody who
would be the way to get to God to get to
know God and if we we if we were alive
me and you Eddie in the time of Jesus
peace and blessings be upon him we would
be from his followers we love him we
would follow him if me and you were
alive in the time of Abraham we would
follow Abraham peace and blessings be
upon him we love him if me and you were
alive in the time of Moses we would
follow him as he's the prophet of that
time we love him peace and blessings be
upon him but we are in the last
prophet's time in in the time of the
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him and that's why we are the
followers of the Prophet Muhammad but we
love all of the prophets and we say
peace and blessings be upon all the
prophets absolutely I want to ask you
about this before we get into Tyrese
here you have three possibilities if
there's a fourth let me know when you
use the word
son in the English language you can have
an adopted son a physical son or it's
some something left to be a metaphor
term of endearment as you would say
right so it's metaphorical right what in
this case would we say is this term
referring to adopted physical or a
metaphor this is we would say for sure
it's a metaphor a term of endearment
yeah because like I mentioned that makes
sense it just it makes I mean look for
example if somebody says Jesus didn't
have a father right Born miraculously we
would say neither did Adam neither did
Eve in fact in the Bible if you look at
the genealogy of Jesus right in the
beginning in in you have it in Matthew
and you have it in Luke right if you go
through the one in Matthew it begins
with Abraham if you go through the one
in Luke and again I don't claim to be a
Bible scholar I'm just somebody who
actually reads the Bible so if you go to
the the genealogy in Luke it will say
now Jesus himself began his ministry
about 30 years of age being as supposed
the son of Joseph it goes on to take
each genealogy in Luke
3:38 it ends with the genealogy going
back to the son of inos the son of Seth
the son of Adam who's the son of God so
here just like uh Seth is called the son
of Adam and inos is called the son of
Seth Adam is called the Son of God well
that doesn't mean Adam is physically the
Son of God even though Adam had no
father and had no mother but this is a
term of endearment right so we would say
that just like when you walk up to
somebody and say son let me speak to you
come here son if somebody's close you're
showing endearment you would say son
just like somebody goes to a preacher or
a pastor or or a priest in the Catholic
church and says forgive me Father for I
have sinned what doesn't mean literally
that's their father it's a term of
respect
yeah some people can take uh this the
wrong way some people can really take to
it um in a loving way and be very
thankful that you're pointing these
things out it's kind of like the person
is a fair assessment who does the DNA
test if uh because you could be invested
in a person let's say you have a person
and he grew up uh you you you grew up
believing he's your father and then
someone comes and brings a DNA test he's
actually not your father he is not the
father so now it's like do you shoot the
guy who just brought brought this
information to you or I know you're
heavily invested in it or do you go
ahead and open your mind and say hold on
this is just the first part of the quest
of the Journey For Truth let me dig a
little bit deeper let me ask the Creator
God Almighty to guide me throughout this
confusion right and many have done this
and they have grown but some people they
get stuck on certain Traditions
following their ancestors and parent
people blindly and they just want to be
stubbornly holding on to things and
we're just bringing this to light
respectfully got into it yeah and I I
want I want to get into um I do want to
mention one thing before you go forward
um if you're a Christian and you're
watching understand we mean this with
the utmost of respect we mean this
having studied the Bible as you can see
my Bible is filled it's not something we
do out of uh ignorance of the text if
you're a Christian go to Matthew take
your Bible out
2639 Matthew
2639 and it says he went a little
further and fell on his face and prayed
Jesus peace and blessings be upon Him
according to the Christian Bible he
prayed saying oh my father is it
possible to let this cup pass from me
nevertheless not as I will but as you
will just think about
that if Jesus was God right which is
what the church tells us fully God while
on Earth Accord according to the
Christian doctrine today the standard
you find in Baptists and uh Protestant
churches and so on including Catholics
Jesus on Earth was fully God fully human
fully God which makes no sense to me
anyway but but just think about this why
would God be praying to God he didn't
pray to himself and why would he tell
God that take this cup away from me I
mean if you're a Christian just think
about this who who was he praying to
meaning take this cup away from this
hardship whatever I'm going through how
how would that now if the plan was for
Jesus to come to the Earth and be killed
for the sins of mankind then why would
he ask God to take it away from him take
this test away this trial but that would
be the plan then why would he tell God
why have you forsaken me who was he
praying too do you ever see in the Bible
the father praying to the son or to the
Holy Ghost you do see Jesus many times
now if you say that's because he was on
Earth then you would have to then admit
that at that time he was no longer God
now now now that was from Matthew
2639 right yes but can you use the same
same thing in when he's on the cross and
he's
saying my God my God why have you
forsaken me exactly if you're getting
into okay this is a plan that he's
coming to die for your sins but you just
gave one example you can connect it with
this doesn't seem like they're on the
same page then with a plan he's no I'm
going to mention one more even though I
wasn't going to but just for fun and
this is uh Mark
13:32 and if you're a Christian pull out
your Bible read it but of that day and
hour no one knows not even the angels in
Heaven nor the son but only the father
now that's a very important point to
take here it doesn't mention the sun on
Earth it doesn't say mention before
after
Resurrection generally it says of the
hour of the return of Jesus that's what
it's referring to nobody knows not the
angels and it specifies nor the son but
only the
father if you're a Christian and your
church is telling you that Jesus is God
he is the same God the Father the same
God above think about that how can God
know and not know at the same time mhm
either God as we see in the Bible knows
everything that's a quality of being God
that he knows everything or he doesn't
know and here it clarifies the son does
not know only the father and if the
church tells you that oh he hid that
knowledge away from himself when he
humbled himself okay but then he wasn't
God
at that time he did not know and if the
father knows he is superior he is
greater than Jesus they cannot be the
same we as Muslims love Jesus we respect
Jesus peace and blessings be upon him
you will never see a Muslim
disrespectful towards the prophet Jesus
but we don't worship him we worship that
same God that Jesus worshiped and if us
worshiping the god of Jesus the god of
Muhammad the god of Abraham peace and
blessings be upon all the prophets makes
us wrong then Jesus would be wrong if
that's what people say because we're
worshiping the same God that Jesus
worshiped we're praying to the same God
that Jesus prayed to so if you're a
Christian why not pray to that one great
Creator the God above that Jesus prayed
to that Abraham prayed to that Moses
prayed to that Muhammad prayed to peace
and blessings be upon all of them yeah
this is a very common sense a lot of the
points you're bringing up and you're
bringing the evidence and can you say
that uh before we go into the Tyrese
here because he talks about Jesus also
and we wanted to touch upon that is the
point that when you translate things you
heard the term Lost in Translation true
I remember when I had a guest on he was
a deacon former Deacon Dr Gerald Dirks I
don't know if you heard of him he
finished uh from the Divinity School of
Harvard I think I saw him on your show
yeah he was here with us may Allah Grant
him Jenai he's passed away since and
when he went into the language and
looking at son son of God when you get
into the Aramaic and whatnot he said and
this was a Bible scholar he's an
academic he said that you can actually
translate this and they translated to
Son but slave or servant of God very
interesting yeah so L lot of these
things now de developed and now we're
translating things from a language now
you mentioned uh where most most of
these were in the New Testament as we
spoke up before this is now in Greek in
a language that Jesus didn't speak he
did not he spoke Aramaic and the
followers of of Jesus peace and
blessings be upon AR make speakers how
much does it play into Greek being with
all the Pagan culture and they're taking
they have already sons of gods also one
thing I find interesting is people most
pastors and preachers if you're
Christian and you go to a a minister ask
him if he speaks K Greek and if he's
fluent in reading and understanding most
of them are not Muslim Scholars and
students of knowledge and people who
study almost all of us the first thing
we do is we learn Arabic myself I'm not
Arab but I learned Arabic and and I
studied the Arabic language because I
wanted to study the Quran in its
original language now interestingly I
have a Interlinear Bible Greek and
English it's a very interesting one I
got it's four volumes the first three
volumes are Hebrew English for the Old
Testament and the fourth volume here is
Greek and English in the uh in the for
the New Testament because the New
Testament was in K Greek now there is a
verse we find very commonly used to say
that Jesus is God and this something
many Christian preachers they will they
will come out and say you know what
Jesus said I am and this is
something uh kind of a um a play on the
language as you were saying being Lost
in Translation that they use where they
will say that in in the Old
Testament God says that he is Yahweh
meaning he is or I am right but that's a
Hebrew word and they try to bring out uh
ego my Greek word Now Greek word now and
make them me to make it say that
means I am so Jesus is the same God of
the Old Testament and what the the verse
that they use here is in
John
um 8 59 right
859 where uh then which they took up
Stones so right before that 858 is where
it begins Jesus he says truly I say to
you before Abraham was I am ego
me here the Greek and this I have with
the Greek and English lining up is used
to say that this is a special name of
God
igimi I am and because Jesus said I am
that means he's claiming to be God of
course now the word God as used for the
father repeatedly could have been used
but it's not they they make up this idea
that this is a clear statement but if
you just read the same chapter same John
you just go about 10 verses further you
go to chapter N9 and you go to verse 9
it talks about the Blind Man chapter n
begins talking about a man who was blind
and uh through the the Dua or the
supplication of the Prophet Jesus Allah
granted him
sight but interestingly the same
discussion goes on when the people ask
about who he is who was the blind man
because he can see now and that man says
igimi the exact same Greek word I mean
if you just go a few verses further you
will find the exact now if that's a
special name of God as Christian
preachers claim that I am igimi in Greek
is a special name that God had for
himself then the blind man must have
been God according to that logic cuz he
says exactly and he stops there there's
a full stop IG that's
it the mistake made here and again I can
show you many others who have used the
exact same name for example if you go to
Luke and this is in New Testament if you
go to Luke
1119 you will find Gabriel the angel
Gabriel he will say IG and this is in
Luke 1119
he will say that Gabriel says that I am
Exacta exact same gording AR Angel
Gabriel is saying I am I am exactly and
you will even find in Matthew same thing
being used by Judas when he's saying
that not I am Judas the betay the betray
betray of Jesus yes when he's when he's
trying to be uh cunning that he's not
the one he uses
egoi I actually looked up uh many uh
Greek dictionaries and I went back and I
spoke to people who are scholars in the
Greek language and what it is is igimi
is a statement that I am the one you're
referring to I'm the one you're
referring to that the subject matter is
me so when they talked about who is the
Messiah Jesus is saying it is me I am
the one that was sent to you that before
Abraham even was I was assigned as the
prophets have been given their jobs
prophets have been chosen by Allah right
not that he existed at that time even
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he said he was given the
prophethood when Adam Even Adam was not
created yet right so it what it's saying
is that I'm the one you're talking about
so it's like God Almighty Allah in in
his ultimate knowledge infinite
knowledge he's prescribing things before
even the creation everything's written
so it's laid out course and no doubt to
that now if this was a special name as
Christians claim then when it's used by
the blind man about himself does that
mean that the blind man is God when
Gabriel uses it for himself does that
mean that he's God when Judas is saying
not me is he talking about not being God
no it is saying I'm the one that you're
talking about I am I am the subject
matter that you are discussing and
that's why it's the exact same word in
Greek is used repeatedly but the problem
is pastors and preachers and
ministers to try to support their own
Dogma they hide the actual verbiage from
the people they say God had this word
Yahweh which is Hebrew and then they try
to translate a Greek name and say this
is a special name and Jesus saying that
I am means that he's saying he's God no
he's not he could Clearly say I'm God
that's not difficult right he's never
never never ever in fact he continuously
says the father is greater than I right
I'll show you something very interesting
in the
Greek um and this was why again I don't
claim to be a scholar of anything I'm
just a student of knowledge but I do
like to read so I went and I looked at a
verse that comes in first Corinthians
chapter8 and this is verse six where
they talk about what they said he said
but for us is only one God the Father
the above the one above to whom all
things and we have for him one Lord
Jesus they clearly
separated Theos being used and Creos as
Lord so they separated a different word
saying there's only one God above and
one representative or a lord or somebody
that was sent that is Jesus right and
this is something you can if they're the
same if Jesus God and the Holy Spirit
according to the idea of the Trinity are
the
same why are they clarifying two
different words right look even if we
just go to the very basic simple English
you will find that repeatedly Jesus says
there is only one God this is eternal
life that they may get to know you the
only true God right this is something
that we find that's a John 173 173
exactly I'm
know that is such a powerful verse right
there yeah it's a very common sense
verse it's a verse that you don't have
to kind of do too much thinking about
it's straightforward if you're a
Christian open up your Bible and go John
173 and this is eternal life that they
may know you the only only true God and
Jesus Christ whom you have sent I call
this the shahada the shahada verse
doesn't it sound like this it does this
is exactly what we say we say that there
is one true God the one above the one
that's created everything the one that's
always Liv the one that never dies the
one that knows everything the one that
was worshiped by Abraham and Moses and
Jesus and Muhammad peace and blessings
be upon them and that God
sent Jesus that that God sent Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon both of them
now some of the Christians will come
back and they will say well Jesus said
me and the father are one right now if
that is taken to mean that they are
physically one then the same chapter
John 17 keep reading to verses
2021 John 177 2021 according to the
Christian Bible and if you're a
Christian take out your Bible read this
according to Christians Jesus says I do
not pray for these alone but also for
those who will believe in me through
their word that they all may be one as
you the father are in me and I in you
that they also may be one in us that the
world may believe that you sent me you
see here when Jesus says me and the
father are one
this is referring to the same Mission
being on the same page that God sent
Jesus not with his own ideas but they
are one just like for example Eddie we
might say we're one nation under God
right in America we say this we don't
mean that we're all physically the same
person we're one family we're one family
we're one in purpose we're one nation
One Tribe one people one love all these
things that we use just like Jesus is
saying that just the same as me and the
father are one the disciples are one and
those that believe in the word are going
to be one in us that doesn't mean
they're physically the
same these are things that we hope that
our Christian neighbors and our
Christian co-workers and others that are
out there will think about and many
people are today you see Brothers like
Andrew Tate and sneo and others that
come from that Christian background when
they realize these things they've
accepted Islam and there are many more
inshallah our brother uh young Don who's
studying right now we're having
conversations inshallah you will see I
hope from Allah that Allah guides him to
Islam that today young Dawn even has
rejected the idea that Jesus is God he's
not the one God above he's making that
progress and we hope that others that
are watching this will think about that
the one God that has always lived can't
be killed he can't not know he can't be
tricked he can't be fooled that is the
creator of everybody that is the god
that knows
everything saying God was fully God and
fully human is like saying there's a
square circle just doesn't make sense
people like can't God do everything it's
not that we're restricting God but think
about that if you're a square you have
four corners that's the definition of a
square and if it's a circle you have no
corners
that's the definition of a circle if you
put Corners it's no longer going to be a
square circle and if you put it to be
with no corners it cannot be a square
it's going to be a circle God knows
everything and if he doesn't he can't be
God because that's not what God is God
is ever living if he's killed he's not
God because that's not who God is and if
somebody doesn't know they cannot be God
if somebody's killed and tortured and
beaten they cannot be God because God is
above
that yeah and uh if the mind's open if
someone's really trying to um get to
ascertain the truth I mean this is
brought to you with love uh because we
love for Humanity we love for ourselves
so we're trying to go ahead and uh share
let's get into um
Tyrese he was someone who brought a lot
of tension when he was visiting the
Dubai and it seemed like like he was
really close to accepting Islam Allah
guide him a mean so something came up
recently and we wanted to go ahead and
maybe reissue an invitation to him and
also kind of break down and get a
reaction to some of his statements from
this video here it's all God right
because you know we should as Believers
we should go the rest of our life trying
to figure out God that should be an
everlasting hunt I just feel like we're
in competition right now because they
are trying to normalize the devil they
are trying to pop they the devil is is
on the main stage at award
show and in every video and signs and
symbols and I said you know what we need
to stop treating our relationship with
Jesus like the little buddy that you
talk to before you go to bed at night
and not be more vocal about all the
things that God means to us and all of
the things that God has brought us
through yeah they going above and beyond
to promote the devil and it's pissing me
off mhm because they used to devil
worshippers used to be real secretive
like going down in the basement this
secret world now they just like now they
on the device too what do you think I
like how we start started off being in
an everlasting hunt yeah if uh somebody
wants to know what the purpose of life
is why they've been creative they got to
seek to like there's a Hadith uh I'll
paraphrase that God Almighty Allah is
saying that all my slaves servants
they're misguided unless I guide them so
ask me of my Guidance Do start from
there that's beautiful yes now I think
that's a great point to make here that
those that worship the devil whether
they do it openly or secretly or whether
they do it explicitly or otherwise have
been coming out of the closet you could
say you saw you've seen that right in
more ways than one um it's becoming more
so evident you've seen it all over right
we're seeing it everywhere you know in
fact what I'm I'm not surprised with
with Hollywood I'm not surprised I I
think Hollywood and a lot of other uh
such um institutions were meant to
misguide people meant to to delute the
masses what I am most shocked about are
the churches you know now today when I
was driving over here um was you know uh
I saw a Methodist church and it was huge
Methodist church and it had a huge
rainbow FL FL on it and you know it was
was there supporting that lgbtqxyz
infinity sign whatever
lifestyle and that's something shocking
to me because that is something we could
not have imagined but those that want to
promote such a lifestyle have now tried
to normalize it to the point that even
churches even the pope has become soft
on these issues and is accepting
and because of the church not having a
backbone not having enough guts enough
courage to stand up what's in their
Bible now you're seeing devil
worshippers as mentioned by Tyrese there
out in open you see them flaunting their
disrespect for God disrespect for
religion disrespect for anything holy
and they're telling you very clearly
we're coming for your kids now know
there's a clip you can play I've sh that
yeah you can see where he talks about
we're here we're queer we're coming for
your kids they're saying this in Pride
rallies openly it's it's not something
hidden and there is a kid you can see
that one from Kentucky 11-year-old kid
being giving a book in his school that
is promoting and
explicitly pushing such immoral
homosexual behaviors that even if that
was a heterosexual Behavior being
described that would not be acceptable
for an 11-year-old to be given from
school but this is an agenda that is now
come in full focus and we as Muslims
alhamdulillah are the ones standing up
against it you see churches falling I
want to read to you something from the
Bible about this and if you're a
Christian and you support the LGBT flag
or your church has it on there or you
try to say that this is their business I
want you to go and open your Bible now
again I'm going to read from the old and
the New
Testament and before anybody says oh the
Old Testament this is the Old Testament
if you're a Christian and you believe in
the god of Jesus then he's the same God
if you believe Jesus as God then these
are the laws Jesus ordained if you
believe in the god of Jesus this is the
laws of the god of Jesus this is in
Leviticus
2013 Leviticus chapter 13 chter 20: 13
if a Man Lies with a male as he lies
with a woman both of them have committed
an Abomination they shall surely be put
to death their blood shall be upon them
this is the Bible this is the Bible it's
not the Quran this is the Bible Old
Testament Leviticus
no I do want to clarify something that I
am not saying that this is something
that people need to take into their own
hands or anything like that I'm just
reading scripture from the Bible that
Christians do give out and claim is the
words of God now somebody might say oh
you know that's the Old Testament well
even if we go to the New Testament if we
go to Romans you will find the same
penalty being used in the New
Testament and before I bring it up I do
want to make make a point that if you're
Christian live by your text you know
either you can say that this is the
words of God this is what we live by and
this is what we're going to stand by
fine or you can say you know I'm not
Christian I don't believe in the Bible
fine but you can't claim to be preaching
the Bible you can't claim to be living
by the Bible and at the same time
violating the rules that are in your
book we as Muslims we live by the Quran
we're proud of the Quran we love the
Quran we don't we don't compromise on
the Quran we're not apologizing about
anything we're not compromising on
anything we're not watering down
anything that's how we are now this is
the New Testament in case somebody tries
to say oh that's Old Testament this is
in Romans CH 1 if you look at verses
27-32 in 27 it says likewise also the
men leaving the natural desire and use
or the natural use of the woman burnt
with their lust for one another men with
men committing that which is shameful
and receiving in themselves the penalty
of their error which is due now what is
that penalty you will see in the same
chapter going down in verse 32 who
knowing the righteous Judgment of God
that those who practice such things are
deserving of death not only do the same
but also those that approve of that
practice now this is in the Bible this
is the New Testament Romans
27-32 the Bible says now again if you're
Christian and you believe this is the
word of God then why do you not live by
it so all you're asking the question is
why don't you adhere to the book that's
it the Bible says that those who commit
such actions and also those who approve
of it is an abomination
deserve death this is in the Bible this
is in the Bible once again for political
purposes I'm making it clear I'm not
giving my own views I'm not telling
anybody to take into their own the law
into their hands I'm just saying this is
for educational purp this is educational
purposes in the Bible that's what it
says
so what Tyrese is mentioning and what I
find disturbing is the followers of the
devil are now coming out of the closet
they're coming the open they're pushing
their agenda and people are not standing
up to it except for Muslims
alhamdulillah the Muslims we're open
we're clear about our stances about our
condemning the practices that are
devilish the practices that are
unnatural those that Pro support or
promote and and push this
churches are out there in the pride
parades you see pastors and preachers
marching with with with those that are
wearing leather outfits and they're
taking little kids I mean you can see
these videos online if if heterosexuals
were doing such disgusting things I
wouldn't put kids in that parade but
having people who were practicing the
practice of the people of Sodom and
Gabor that that were cursed by God in
the Bible those that the Old Testament
and the New Testament clearly condemn
with death and pastors and preachers are
out there dancing Popes are out there
trying to soften their stances why
because these churches have sold out
they have been bought with money by the
by the people who have their devilish
agenda and that's why people like Tyrese
are upset they're seeing that the people
of God are not taking a stand but we as
Muslims are and our brother Andrew Tate
as you know one of the reasons he came
to Islam is he said this is the only
religion left today this is the only
people that take the religion seriously
they're the only people that stand for
anything alhamdulillah and we ask Allah
to protect us and keep us firm and not
let us sell out like those that want us
to sell out uh do you think something
like a way of
life that is accepted by God it's in the
Quran it's in the Bible do you think
they would promote it and there's a ton
of evidence for it via uh like they do
these um what's against the Bible
against the Quran polygyny for instance
what do you think if they were educating
Humanity on how a man can have multiple
families take care of them nothing
sexual or anything but just show how it
can actually work how it can benefit
Society well that's the funny thing if
you if you look at polygamy um you will
find it throughout the Old Testament you
you will find reference to those same
prophets like David in the Old Testament
you see him having many many wives see
Solomon for example and you'll see
others and you will find the same people
praised in the New Testament for example
David he's called a prophet in the New
Testament so that lifestyle was the
natural lifestyle of the people of God
it was not condemned until you see
Romans and their influence coming in so
that there being something that would
help Humanity to be honest right meaning
if you look at it just from a a
perspective of nature take it back right
we're not even talking about religious
text if there is a man and he marries a
woman and they have children the human
species furthers it goes on now whether
he has one wife or he has two or three
human species goes further it moves on
now if a man marries a man or a woman
marries a woman what happens here they
don't have children the human species
doesn't procreate doesn't go forward now
if that becomes a trend if that becomes
common the human species ceases to exist
and this is a very dangerous thing I
mean people don't realize this but many
European countries are having loss of
population and even though they speak
bad about immigrants they're only
surviving because of immigrants because
one the heterosexuals of that Society
are not having children they're too
worried about partying and living it up
and the homosexuals obviously cannot
have children so Society is starting to
fall apart you know you need as some
Studies have said 2.3 or you know two
and a half or whatever but more than two
children per man and wife for a society
to to survive just to survive you need
more than two because some children will
die you know and so on now if you start
to say men are marrying men and women
are marrying women here those can cannot
now reproduce they can adopt but then
they're adopting from a heterosexual
right so you look at the the fact that
humanity is in danger if these
Lifestyles become prevalent it's
something people don't want to talk
about when polygamy for example would
help Humanity grow right so people don't
use the same standard people don't want
to talk about the Bible they don't want
to talk about religious sex they don't
want to even talk about the betterment
of society and the and the survival of
the human race they just want to ask you
what are your pronouns you and you know
this is something
insane if you're heterosexual or
homosexual you need to thank
heterosexuals because you're even here
if it wasn't for us who have the natural
way of life Humanity wouldn't be
here we don't even get to the point
where we're dividing People based on
their sexual preferences in Islam you
notice that
you get what I'm saying that that now I
mean these are your obviously there's
what's Haram what's Halal what's of
course now islamically are they are
there these categorizations about the
way they've divided people into uh no no
in Islam we don't have any of this
Insanity about trans and what gender do
you think you are and no we know that
Allah the god
the creator of the universe created us
as men and women that's it right and
there is a natural method if you're
alive right now if you're alive right
now it's because a man and a woman came
together right yeah you you could not be
Sur alive right now if it wasn't for
that that's what we go by this is the
natural way now some people may have
feelings or inclinations or desires that
are are not the same meaning somebody
might be
attracted to a wall or a monkey or their
sister you know and if you say love is
love then why is incest strong right we
say no there is a moral code there is a
natural way that was ordained by the
Creator above and that's what humanity
is lived by whether you go to the Old
Testament or the New Testament or you go
to Hinduism or this or that you will
find that men women get married have
children that's how Society works and
these are not our opinion this is from
divine revelation once again we are
simply and this is a freedom of religion
that the constitution allows people I
mean the first off we are simply reading
from the text not just Muslim texts but
from Christian and Jewish Old Testament
New Testament text what those texts say
we
have to as people of conscience as
people of morality at least be able to
State our view you know if people have
the right to insult others and burn
qurans and make uh cartoons inciting
hatred why can't we as Muslims just
State quot the text what not just our
text we're in line here with the Old
Testament the New Testament Quan withr
text and the the Muslim text but we but
they want to scare us by being cancelled
they want to mute us and we cannot allow
that the First Amendment of the
Constitution of the United States allows
us to have these views and express them
yeah just moving along to what he was
saying a few other things it's
interesting as a musician him also
pointing out the symbols in the music
and the messages that are in there that
are dangerous these satanic messages I
actually recently did a breakdown of uh
a documentary that really goes into deep
the black magic behind all the the music
how they use these musical instruments
and you know these musicians and then
they put the poison in there and they
put all this to get into because
naturally if you're listening by to the
lyrics by themselves y it's not going to
get in you but then next thing you know
you got the woman singing she's a ho
naturally normally she wouldn't but the
Beats got into her and now she's like
degrading her you know I mean if you
look at the music history and I know
many brothers that were involved in it
or in to some extent or the other that
got out of it it is a very devilish
industry and some are very open about it
I mean uh we have a brother that used to
be with us in San Diego that was a
professional model and he spoke about uh
himself and his interactions in
Hollywood and also his wife who used to
be a a makeup model uh you know on I
don't know on Tik Tok or Instagram or
something like that and she was offered
some uh opportunities in Hollywood and I
have a interview that I did with him
that's on our one message Foundation
Channel and he talked about where they
took her to go to worship the grave of
other people to to do Satanic rituals
these are not things that are hidden but
people outside the industry may not know
about it but these are well known I mean
from very early on Jimmy Hendrick and so
on you found uh relationships with the
devil if you look at aie Osborne and so
on you saw their relationship with the
devil uh Tupac spoke about it he spoke
about the industry and their devilish
Tendencies and how he was you know uh
kind of on the outskirts because of it
um is a comedian Cat Williams he he
spoke about a lot of the uh rituals that
they have homosexual rituals that he
witnessed himself um David Chappelle
spoke about it uh you know a lot of
these people who run Hollywood who run
the music industry are involved in the
lgbtqxyz lifestyle there are people who
clearly and openly worship the devil
they're involved in Satanic rituals
whether they're doing it through the
Mason temples or whatever else I mean
I'm not a conspiracy theory guy I'm a
facts guy and these things are facts I
mean there are people who will tell you
what they saw people that were involved
in that lifestyle um you know even if
you look at professional wrestlers you
know used to be called WWE or W now it's
called W WWF WWF right um you know
there's Rowdy Piper I believe he wasy Ry
Piper yeah we grew up watching him big
buff guy you know tossing people around
and he was molested he was made to do
homosexual acts to be and I mean you
wouldn't think you look at these big
strong guys but that industry is such a
devilish industry and he gives an
interview and he talks about it you know
um
which tells you we need to be very
careful as Muslims or you know even if
you're a Christian or Jewish or just a
person of conscious you need to be very
careful what your kids watch what you
watch what you listen to what your kids
listen to because there is an agenda
there and that agenda is becoming more
as Tes mentioned here is becoming very
out in the open they're becoming more
and more aggressive with that devilish
agenda and you've had a lot of uh
musicians also come out that and talk
about how with the different beats and
everything that they use that these are
tools that the devil uses to bring him
to his way yeah to put you in a Trent to
put you in a different there was a
concert just like you have the Quran
people heal the hearts with the Quran
yes right it's through words sh yeah
it's yes a healing but with these
instruments and this music and these
symbols all these things these are the
tools of the devil the Shayan this is
what many of these musicians are even
coming out and saying yeah there was a
concert I forgot got the name he was a
rapper uh and they I mean I I don't
listen to him so I don't know but what I
read about from the news was people got
into this trans like devilish mood where
they started stomping and killing and
many and he continued people were
getting killed with MH pits and stuff it
was a rapper um I don't again because I
don't okay yeah yeah I heard that on the
news yeah is that little NS or one of
those guys no somebody knew
um he had like a shoe brand after him
too and stuff but but uh but very
interestingly he continued playing the
music while people were being killed in
that crazy frenzy and when I was reading
the article the people were like we were
out of our minds the devil had taken
over our B these were statements by some
of the people wow and there was a lot of
criticism that he continued playing even
though he could see people were being
hurt
and you know people can look up the
article um it's quite it's quite
dangerous and it's very scary yeah let's
move on to um last thing I want to talk
about we had it scheduled to have je
pearly on the program actually and we
ended up they ended up on there
adjusting the dates but we wanted to
talk about because there was some
controversy and people respect the
position uh that she comes out kind of
um talking about some tradition values
nice and kind of crushing the feminism
that's really gotten and affected a lot
of the minds of even the the Muslim
Community male and female yeah prot so
but then she ended up having some
questions and they turned into kind of
insults and we wanted to see how we can
address those sure and maybe get her to
uh shift if she has some questions
because she's uh had Andrew Tate on her
program quite a while and then she
doesn't want to in offend her guest also
I'm sure but uh hopefully we can address
this issue because you've talked about
it a lot someone actually sent me uh
sent us a message regarding this
question here I sent your video that you
just recently did the person replied and
said wow uh they it was cleared up they
said wow this really put a different
perspective on it excellent so she said
she goes to say did
Muhammad date a 9-year-old or not why is
everybody arguing about this he either
did or he didn't well she was here she
would have been here how how would you
uh address well the answer is he didn't
because there's no such thing as dating
in Islam right um well let's just be
very explicit and clear he never dated
never Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
never dated never had a girlfriend never
went out on a date that dating is not
something in Islam yeah and uh I don't
know her well I mean I the only reason I
know her is because you mentioned her
and a few other people mentioned that
you know she is uh kind of the female
version of The Red Pill meaning that
she's going against a lot of things in
female a female version version of The
Red Pill of the red pill for our
audience what does that mean red pill
well so there is the again I I don't
support the movement but there is a
movement you're green pill I'm not any
pill I I don't touch pills I just I just
drink tea the Islam pill I'm Islam pill
um so basically uh there is this push
for feminism and feminism and I just
spoke about this in one of the lectures
at Maj here in Chicago um where this
idea originally feminism was to promote
things like women's right to own
property women's right to be able to
work or women's right to uh you know be
able to have their own money and their
own um lifestyle within bounds right and
that's something that Islam already
granted inheritance property money own
businesses Islam had already granted
women more than 1400 years ago so
feminism would never have been a thing
if people lived by Islam those rights
would have already been given later on
feminism became what I would say
feminism on crack you know it kind of
went off hand you know it started to say
things like women shouldn't be at home
women shouldn't be raising children
women should go out there and and and be
the same as men not equal but the same
right and and that's why feminism is
kind of Fallen apart and feminists today
are kind of infighting because you have
these trans women who are actually men
and now some feminists would say Well
they're women CU they they they identify
as women and they should be playing
sports with women and other feminists
are like no way these guys are guys they
they will destroy women in sports
because physically they're men right so
now feminists are fighting amongst
themselves because instead of being
about equal rights and things it began
to be a movement about women not no
longer being the traditional role of a
woman starting to be a man right where
they would encourage things like taking
hormones and things to make a woman more
manly and again that's wrong because
you're offsetting the natural method of
things
and people in a reaction to this extreme
feminist movement was the red pill
movement trying to make men um back to
being leaders and manly but at the same
time going to an extreme sometimes um in
their ideas we as Muslims we're not
feminists we're not red pillars we're
not we're Muslim we don't have to worry
about these kind of things because we
have a Divine truth we have the Quran we
have the Sunnah of the
Prophet peace and blessings be upon the
prophets this tells us how to live
what's the role of a man what's the role
of a woman what's the role of a child
what's the role of a father what's the
role of a neighbor we don't have to
guess at these things we don't have to
argue we go back to the Divine our
creator knows best how we should live so
we go back to what our creator has told
us and we live by that so the red pill
was kind of this movement and we see
some uh even some Muslim Brothers kind
of caught up in it um but uh just pearly
or pearly things or whatever um you know
from what I've heard from you and others
you know she had a good influence to try
to do away some of this toxic feminist
ideology that was out there um and we
appreciate that uh but again she may not
be educated about Islam so let's educate
her and again you can welcome her to
your show and she can come and speak to
you as well um I have a video if anybody
wants to see more details like you said
if you putb far age OFA you can see the
video and I give a lot of details and
things without getting into all of that
um may Allah be pleased with her a me
she was of age to be married right
according to the society and customs of
the time there is no doubt because she
was already engaged to be married before
a woman
came to the prophet peace be upon him
and suggested her for marriage this was
not something that the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him was going out and
trying to find a wife and look no the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him as a prophet of God he was
married to Khadijah Khadijah was his
first wife and as long as he was married
to Khadijah he never took a second wife
he was happy she was happy great husband
great wife and no doubt she was older
than him he was married to a woman that
was older than him now some people said
she was 40 which is not mentioned
authentic narrations most likely she was
around 25 to 28 at the time of marriage
to the prophet peace and blessings be
upon him but again even at that she
would be older than him so he was
married to a woman who was older and
they were happy when she passed away
when she died then it was suggested to
him that there is a woman in soda and
there is a woman named Aisha and these
are women that are there at marriage age
of the customs of that time now here I
don't know where she got this idea of
dating there was no dating at that time
there are some narrations that are in
bukari and Muslim and so on that mention
ages one of them mentions that before
before marriage that she was at the age
of six another one from her mentioned
that she was seven now again this is not
a time of marriage this is at the time
when she was s suggested these are from
her herself right now what I will point
out first thing that this is not
mentioned in the Quran the age of AA is
not in the Quran secondly it's not
mentioned from the
prophet meaning what we
consider we divine revelation whether
Quran or from the
prophet it is not mention either one of
them rather this was something that she
mentioned and she is an incredibly
intelligent amazing person great narr in
Hadith very strong in narration but
again she's talking about something that
she didn't witness she didn't witness
her own birth I mean if I ask you Eddie
how old are you you don't know other
than going back to your passport or your
birth certificate or asking your parents
now imagine a society where you don't
have any of those you don't have a birth
certificate you don't have a passport
you don't have uh even the system of
years years right right now is 2023
right so if somebody's born in the year
2000 how old are they 23 years old how
do you know because we're born in 2000
now imagine if we didn't have those
numbers how would you know You' be like
well you know that year when it rained a
lot um well 10 years after that you were
born and then it's been another 5 years
I think so you would kind of figure that
out in a in a roundabout manner right my
own grandmother had no idea when she was
born you know um you know she was 14
when she got married but you know she
really didn't know you were guessing you
know many people today if you go to like
you know many of our brothers from
Somalia they came to the US if you look
at their their passports they're all
born on January 1st you I don't know
what happened N9 months before January
1st but somehow you know and that's
because in Somalia they didn't really
care when you were born so didn't record
it so when they came to the US they just
kind of made up January 1st first day of
the year solar calendar and they went
with with that so that tells you that
keeping Ages was not an exact science at
the time and that's why herself in one
of the narration she says I was six and
another one she says I was seven and
those are authentic narrations again
this not a criticism of the narrations
or her memory she was amazing but she's
just telling you what other people told
her about something that happened before
when she was not even under
Consciousness right but what we do know
for sure is that she was at the age of
marriage according to Society of that
time and they didn't get married at that
age they waited until she was
physically capable of handling a married
relationship which is past the age of
puberty when the body naturally tells
you you are ready for marital life and
then they got married whether that was
at nine or older or so on that was the
customs of the time now this idea that
this wasn't a custom of the time that
some people have mentioned is stupidity
they don't study
why first and foremost she was already
engaged so if this was not a custom of
the time then how could she already been
engag secondly nobody objected to it all
the enemies of the Prophet all those
polytheists that were there finest a
single narration where they objected to
this being something against the customs
of the time we cannot use presentism you
know what presentism is when you use
present Jud exactly standards to judge
the past
otherwise if you look at the age of Mary
at the time that she was married to
Joseph now somebody might say well
that's not in the Bible Well the age of
a is not in the Quran right but if you
look at historic documentation that
discusses the age of Mary you can look
at the Catholic encyclopedia you can
look at many Christian writings they
will say she was either 12 to 14 years
of age marrying Joseph being 80 to 90
years of age now imagine today if a
12-year-old Mary married a 90-year-old
Joseph who would accept that that would
be given all kinds of bad names and so
on but when we mention that people say
well well who well easy there that was
the tradition of the time that women at
12 would marry 89 year old men well okay
if you want to accept that being a
tradition of the time then the age of
was in accordance to the tradition of
the
time you mentioned also in your talk
there was her sister
yes and she gave other ages and and
other historians because again people
don't realize historian didn't really
discuss ages like saying okay they're
this age because they were born in this
day rather what they would do is they
look at the death dates and they would
kind of work backwards because the death
dates were better known right because
before Islam there was no calendar Omar
the second Khalifa he's the one that
implemented the hij calendar and that
calendar is start from when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam peace be upon
him made the migration from mekah to
Madina so later they were able to
calculate their lifespans easier looking
at the death dates looking at that there
are ages given that put in her teens
right at the time of her marriage but
again I'm not arguing which one is more
authentic and things the whole point
here is that according to the custom of
the time she was already engaged and she
was at an age that was acceptable for
marriage of that time in our time even
boys for example don't get married young
why because they have to go to school
and they got to go to high school then
they got to go to college right get a
job but in societies where they don't
have that structure basically when your
body is ready when a woman is hit
puberty and a man has hit puberty
they're ready to get married right and
they waited for her for her body to be
mature and her mind to be mature to an
age where she could be married and that
is why they waited for the actual
marriage right this is what is important
at that time people don't go to school
right when a girl would for example one
of the one of the ways that you know a
girl is ready for that type of
relationship is when she gets her Menses
right this is the body telling you that
you are now ready for child birth now
mentally according to the Society of the
time she might not be ready right that's
you don't have to get married but this
is a natural phenomena so when a woman
is physically ready for her to get
married this is perfectly acceptable
today you have many pre-teens that are
out engaging in sexual behavior right
you see pregnant teen
teenagers and there's no law against
that there's nobody upset you know I
used to work at a school called Twain as
a Mark Twain in San Diego as a
teachers's assistant and there were
girls as young as 14 15 that had already
had kids they used to have a daycare at
the school for these you know teenager
girls with kids now if they're old
enough to be having kids and old enough
to be having sex why aren't they old
enough to be married right in Islam we
don't believe in premarital sex right so
again in accordance to the customs of
the time she was already engaged to be
married no we objected to that she was
engaged to the prophet peace be upon him
and married to him in a age that was
customary of that time and people want
details we have a video on it they can
look at it for details so the question
is on what standards are you judging so
if you're judging by the culture the
culture didn't condemn it if you're
judging by the law any religious law
there's no religious law no that
condemns it if you're judging by her
family you already mentioned she was
engaged to already be married so any
which way you go and if you want to
compare it to some close to Modern Times
let's say the founding fathers were they
people who now were breaking some kind
of laws were they these terms the
derogatory terms the founding fathers
first off even if you leave that out
many of the kings in Europe and go
further back I try to go closer if you
go back so let's take it step by step
many of the Kings married women that
were six that were seven that were nine
and so on and this was accepted in
Europe right past that going forward if
you look at many of the founding fathers
if you find many of even the the
well-known personalities and in my in my
video I go through details on these they
married women that were underage
according to our standard of today many
of the founding fathers were slave
owners if you look at George Washington
he owned slaves but when we bring that
up people say well well that was
acceptable at the time well then if that
was acceptable at the time and you want
to put him on the dollar bill on Mount
Rushmore saying that you know he was
acceptable by the time of today it's not
acceptable then that's presentism right
so no problem but then you need to use
the same rule if you look at the Bible
and if you we can do a breakdown of
actual verses that'll take you over the
age of Rebecca when she's married to
Isaac according to the Bible she was
three years old Rashi the famous
commentator uh of the Old Testament he
says that this is Jewish law that a girl
pass three years of age can get married
right now again I'm not saying that
that's right or wrong I'm just showing
that if you're going to talk if you're
going purposes if you're going to
criticize you better look at your texts
right if you look at some of the states
now even to this day I mean if you go
further back I think it was uh 189
something around there Delaware was
seven I think in the 80s in the 80s they
raised the age yeah um but until then
but it was as low as 7 8 9 10 when you
go back in some states I went over this
in my video till today at I think it's
10 or 12 years of age with parental
consent they can get married yeah so the
further uh back you go you had more
Traditional Values being upheld you
didn't have this whole institution of
schooling University and then not to
talk about the lifespan all these things
you take into
consideration and also the the maturity
level was nowadays you have some women
can't boil an egg well I mean some men
men the 30 40 year old guys are still
playing sitting there playing
and they're not they're not they're
mentally less than 12 years of age
exactly so men and women not mature
these are if you if just can you imagine
if you look at someone you know I was
looking the other day what was he 19
years old uh mhmed was it mhmed the
Conqueror yeah 19 was he 19 years old he
was a general opening up C Muhammad bin
kasim was 17 Usama bin Z was 17 how do
you wrap your mind around that yeah yeah
of course I mean not just that if even
if you you look at earlier cultures
people by the time of 12 and 13 men even
had already had children today today I
live in San Diego we right next to
Mexico right if you go into Mexico and
you go to Inner Mexico not just Tijuana
and Wes if you go inside if you go to
some outskirts of caloa and walara you
will find 14-year-old girls that are
married and have kids right now that may
not be acceptable by our standards in
the US you have to be whatever age but
that's wrong for us to judge them by our
standards unless there is something in
text religious text or in uh natural
development then yes but when a woman is
at the age that she's having her menus
this is a body telling you naturally
she's ready for that type of
relationship and when people are okay
with children that age engage engaging
in sexual activity but not okay with
getting married that's just hypocrisy
mhm when you look at men if you look at
some of these um I'll take for example
the Mormons if you look at um what was
the Mormon Joseph Joseph Smith and many
like him who later when they get locked
up or things get revealed you got women
coming out and they're talking about all
of the all of the different uh criminal
things that uh he was doing and the
impostor he was and they on him
basically but that's the amazing thing
Prophet Muhammad peace and blessing be
upon him you don't have no such thing
from any of his wives now particularly
Aisha when you look at her she grew to
be a scholar somebody who would have
been abused somebody who taken advantage
of you would have see
traumatized uh they would have um a
totally different mindset totally be in
a different position but her you had the
companions Disciples of prophet Muhammad
they would go behind the
and get Knowledge from her cuz she was a
scholar she was a scholar and she she
praised the prophet peace and blessings
be upon him saying that his his
mannerisms were the best he was a
walking
Quran Quran his mannerisms were like as
if you see the Quran in action she she
loved the prophet peace and blessings be
upon him she she continued to narrate
Hadith those statements about from the
prophet peace be upon him after his
death peace blessings be upon him and no
doubt she became a great example of a
wonderful wife a scholet very educated
very eloquent till today if we go back
to the books of Hadith where we look at
the narrations or the books of T about
the explanation of the Quran or the
books of f about Islamic Juris Prudence
I challenge anybody to find a single
book of Hadith that doesn't have a
narration from her or a single T of
Quran that doesn't go to the Quran and
not depend on her opinions or books of
that will mention her opinions to show
what a great example she was and what a
wonderful woman she was she was our
mother in the sense that we are the
Believers she's our mother we love her
and we respect her and no doubt that she
herself praised the life she lived with
the prophet peace and blessings be upon
him and how wonderful it was and what a
great character he was if just pearly if
she now I mean she probably agrees would
agree with a lot of because because
people when you explain Islam about
worshiping the Creator not the creation
living a morally upright life all the
principles and all the the basics of
Islam they just make sense now people
get stuck on some of these things that
need a little more clarification things
that might like we explained something
is a CO something that's going on 1,400
years ago that's the norm and now you
want to bring it into today so if
someone like pearly she's like okay I
just can't WRA my mind I I agree there's
only one God to be worship I believe
Jesus is not God but he's a messenger of
God I believe that like she does that a
woman should be feminine a man should be
masculine all those things she's like
yes yes it but now she's stuck here you
talk about this not being a theological
thing it's not a credal issue and if
she's looking at you and she's like you
know what this whole calendar thing
maybe she could have been 12 and it's
interesting she says I can accept 12
well why can she accept 12 so if she
says look I want to keep it at 12 I'm if
I can I be a Muslim and I I just want to
I want to believe that AA was 12 look
what do you do the age of is not a cedos
not a issue yes right like I said even
the authentic narrations mentions for
example engagement when the first
happened at six and seven and other
Scholars like I mentioned whether
they're strong and weak narrations and
so on it's not the point have given
different ages and so on so that's not
really a point of contention to stop
somebody from being Muslim but my
question to her would be why would you
accept 12 and not 10 or not 9 or not 11
or not 14 where did you who draws that
line who draws that line now if you mean
nature in the sense if I'm leaving uh
any religious values out of this in the
sense when the body has those signs of
maturity then no doubt the prophet peace
be upon him as mentioned in the Hadith
waited to consummate the marriage until
she was physically ready as natural
signs of immaturity have come so then if
that's your issue then you should agree
right now if you make up some number
then where did you get that number from
what's your like today we say 18 where
do we get 18 from and if somebody is 17
years old and 11 months are they
suddenly not ready for marriage and the
next month they are you see these are
arbitary numbers we've made up and like
you said and like I mentioned in my
video if we look at our own history in
this country and also in other European
countries and other Chinese and African
traditions and South American traditions
earlier times when they didn't have
schools they all got married young that
when your body was ready you got married
and that's exactly 14400 years ago we're
talking about that's exactly what they
did in accordance to the customs of that
time and nobody objected to that because
that was the custom she was already
engaged right this is something that
people don't think about the fact that
she was already engaged to be married
according to the customs of the time and
the prophet peace and blessings be upon
Him waited for consummation until she
was physically and mentally ready for
marriage physically and mentally so
these that's the criteria of course in
Islamic Juris Prudence if those that
study Islamic you will find like in the
books
like ofi and
others uh they talk about how what is
the age and they never give just a break
point rather they say that a person who
is physically and mentally ready for
marriage can get married and there would
be women in the past as talks about Al
who would be kind of the Physicians of
the time we didn't have doctors or
gynecologists and so on that could even
go and check to see if a girl is
physically you know with menis and so on
and mentally ready for her marriage and
then they would permit her to be married
MH because if we if we put like a age
you know women in different parts of the
world get their menes at different ages
which is a physical sign of being ready
for child birth right so if we set a age
how would we use that one number across
the board in different cultures in
different time periods that's why Islam
is such a beautiful religion it's not a
religion just for our time or a thousand
years ago or a thousand years from now
rather it is the truth from the time of
the Prophet peace be upon him till the
day of judgment so it has to facilitate
all these different time periods in
different places so Islamic Juris
Prudence tells us that there is no magic
number here rather when a woman is
physically and mentally ready for
marriage according to the the customs of
the place she can get married mhm so
we'd ask uh if you have any questions
ask them be respectful about
sure and if you can add a link to my
video which gives you more details and
reference to all the books in the
description people can go look up far
age OFA and Google or YouTube as well
and we give you all the details there so
if pearly has any other questions feel
free to ask feel free to ask over here
to help you along your way you were
recently also visiting uh Indonesia yes
and it was interesting you had an
experience where people uh you you're
starting to see this here you know
people it's a shame you know parents
bringing their kids and you got grown
men showing genitalia you know here
disgusting but now you talk about that
in Indonesia and a certain what village
and yeah so I had a very interesting
experience I mean um I went from here uh
I went forra and then I went to Malaysia
uh the people of Malaysia are wonderful
people had a great time there then I
went to Indonesia and the people of
Indonesia are wonderful people had a
great time there I stopped in Thailand
for a day where our brother Bobby
accepted Islam and may Allah protect him
and keep him on the right path and then
I went back to Saudi Arabia did again
and then came back to the US but one
thing I was going to discuss uh that I
found very interesting in Indonesia is
there was an area that we went and this
uh is is a very very long drive away
from Jakarta I landed in Jakarta but I
mean we used to drive like 12 hours 7
hours sometimes 20 hours in a day to get
to different places Indonesia is a huge
country um a beautiful country and
wonderful people um we went to an area
that was a very far drive and in that
area you couldn't go any further in cars
the rest was jungles right and we met
some people and these people live the
area they live in is a 4-day hike
there's no cars and there's no roads
that can go there you hike through the
jungle and there's about 800 that of the
population that still lives like this
but they're not Muslim um some of them
the missionaries have come out there and
people talk about oh in Muslim countries
missionaries aren't allow I mean in
Indonesia they said there was about
3,000 Christian missionaries from
different factions Mormons and Je
Witnesses and Catholics and Protestants
that were active the same time that I
was there and they have open missionary
stands where they give out Bibles and so
on but they were out there and they
they've also been reaching out to these
people but these people still live like
what you would think about Tarzan and we
have footage we're going to be posting
as well on the one message Foundation
Channel um but you will see that these
people they're cannibals till today and
this was shocking to me in a country
like Indonesia which is the largest
Muslim population you still have people
living like this they have incest they
have no law
if you go in their area just as you are
they could just shoot you with an arrow
and take your stuff and eat you so
alhamdulillah we met some of those
people we gave them dawa we'll have the
videos up inshallah and many of them had
already become Muslim and some of them
did become Muslim and when we spoke to
them about their lifestyle it was
shocking to me that in today's time in
day and age modern present day there's
still people living Liv like this where
they live in trees or they they don't
even have houses they just make little
huts and things within the trees and
they live there and they don't have a
concept of marriage whoever is forceful
can just take a woman and you know
what's interesting to me is when I was
looking at that I found a
shocking similarity to where our society
is going now these people were primitive
like that they've stayed like that from
the old old days but as people became
more advanced and more Progressive and
more developed and more educated and
more civilized they started to clothe
themselves right so these people till
today they walk around naked I mean they
have some things they tie but they could
walk around full nudity right and they
had no morals of okay this is incest
this is wrong this is homosexual this is
federal this is you shouldn't kill you
shouldn't steal right right as people
developed we got away from that and we
came to a moral code no you need to
dress up you can't walk around naked no
you can't just sleep with anybody you
want you should get married and this and
this right but today's society is going
back to being primitive we're getting
you know we're not we're not getting
better we're getting worse again worse
we now we're going back to people
walking around naked we're going back to
people not having morality we're going
back to people
trying to justify stealing and killing
whether you know it's capitalism or big
fish eats little fish or whatever else
justifications that we give and priscu
um you know infidelity and all those
things are being justified today through
people trying to take us back to A
Primitive age Islam brings us towards
being the most civilized you know this
is why somebody came to me and said oh
you know you guys are real primitive
because your women cover and I mean we
cover as well you don't see me walking
around and you know tight shorts and
things either so I told this lady I told
her well what were the cave people like
and she was like they were naked and I
said okay well what happened when people
became civilized she said well people
started covering up I said then that
means we're the most civilized our women
are the most covered up our men are the
most covered up and you walking around
you know practically naked you're going
You're primitive you're backwards not us
you know and and you see that's
happening more and more you see
what was at one time not too long ago in
the 20s 30s women had uh more even even
even men and then what happens now the
the skirts from below the knee to the
ankles now it's uh uh just below the
knee now it's above the thigh and it
just keeps less less less it just now
you know may Allah protect us all you
look at Society especially in Europe you
see it even worse than the US um you
know you have people that have naked
runs that they run around the streets
naked and you know you got little kids
and you got things like this and you
look at the pride parades and the
disgusting things that go on that's what
I can't understand parents actually
bringing their children to this you know
I think that should be criminal really I
mean you know the human mind has certain
stages that it develops and when you
expose the child's mind to things that
it is not developed for you will have
psychological issues in the future and
this something that psychologist others
will tell you across the board and when
you have people take their little kids
to a pride parade where you have men
dressed up in leather like dogs and you
know doing things to each
other I don't know how any parent can
take their children expose them to that
I don't know how that's not illegal I
don't know how that's not you know
against their own moral reality you know
and and this is uh like the video you
played earlier of Tyrese this this is
becoming more and more in the public eye
more and more common and and Christians
Jews even if you're atheist where you're
a moral person you need to start taking
stances we're Muslims are standing you
guys need to stand with us and say look
this is enough we can't accept this this
is something that is going to destroy
Society uh you know you look at Sodom
and Gabor and the Bible as well in the
Quran about the of lam and the
destruction that it brought we see our
soci heading the same way and we as
Muslims who want good for our society
who want to keep this Society upon
morality the same morality in the Old
Testament in the New Testament in the
Quran and other texts as well are
standing up for it this is how so
societies of the past the Roman Empire
and others this is what happened when
they started going down this direction
they were destroy the Greek and others
too one thing I want to touch upon when
you're talking to people there's from
one side
they tried to create this confusion and
this suspicion of Muslims so they turn
they throw out this term and when people
hear this term called tea now they're
like no matter what you say they're like
they're just lying you know how can we
trust them how would you address this
well first of all uh people don't
understand there is no such uh practice
in
Islam is not an Islamic practice you
find this mentioned in some of the Shia
some of the ra some of the uh books that
are mentioned by them in trying to
protect their identity they would say
it's okay to lie and so on but that's a
Shia concept that is not M the temporary
marriages the lying these are not in
Islam they're not in the Quran they're
not in Hadith you will not find this in
the F in the Juris Prudence of Abu
hanifah or Malik or Shafi or Ahmed and
so on these are Concepts that certain
sects may have developed but they're not
mainstream Islamic Concepts you will not
find them in the Quran or the Sunnah now
if people want to talk about lying and
deceiving you know what before people
get on a high horse I would say that
they need to read the text of their own
book if you look in the Bible for
example in 2 Chronicles 18
20-22 this is in the Bible 2 Chronicles
18 20 to 22 so you're bringing this up
now the Bible because this usually comes
from not all Christians right but mostly
we see Christian apologists bringing
this concept up they'll bring this up of
course and and and this was brought up I
had a Conservative Christian I came on
his talk show and he interviewed me he
threw this at me but then I actually ref
I said no this is nowhere in Islamic
text it is not I went into what you're
allowed to do like let's say your wife
cooks you a meal and it doesn't taste
good even the details that here you can
go ahead and say it's great honey even
though you're lying she put too much
that's not anyway right that has nothing
to do with basically that you know if
there are certain situation like
situations of War well obviously if
you're a general in your war and there's
You Know The Enemy is going to ask you
hey where are your forces coming from
you're not going to tell them that's I
mean if you look at any country that's
been at War they always want to keep
their plan secret so in that situation
State secrets of course I mean you know
Hitler and chural didn't go around
telling their plans to everybody like
when Muslims saved actually the Jews
from Hitler from they were hiding them
and they were coming they were actually
right exactly when they would ask hey do
you have any Jews here and they would
say no this is because they're
protecting their lives in that situation
of course or you know if two brothers
are fighting and you bring some you say
hey you know what he's really sorry why
don't you go talk to him you're just
trying to bring two people together but
the concept is not this is where you're
going to lie to defend your beliefs to
advance your beliefs right and that is
not an Islamic concept this is why if
they're going to bring this tell them
bring the Quran show us where is it you
know so there was a brother um he was
new to Islam and he was at the dawa
Center he was getting educated and he
was like okay there was a Christian
about to come and they were going to do
some daah and have an educational uh
session he said let me even though he
was a Muslim he just started practicing
he says let me tell them that I used to
be a Christian that might help and the
Muslim teacher said no we are not
allowed to deceive this is true specific
from the prophet so we don't deceive
yeah we're not deceivers exactly you
know um but if you if you go to the
Quran for example even many of the
verses that people misquote
like you look at the context of that is
when the people were plotting against
the Muslims and Allah tells them this is
of the Ayah that they have their plans
and plots and that's why every
translation he will find that this is
for plotting if you look at sah
International or M Khan all of those
right and Allah is is has his own plans
and Allah is the best of planners no
doubt to that but if you go to the Bible
this is 2 Chronicles 18: 20-22 it's very
clear then a Spirit came forward and
stood before the Lord before God here
and said I will persuade him the Lord
said to him in what way he said so he so
the spirit said I will go out and be a
lying spirit in the mouth of All His
prophets meaning a a lying spirit will
be placed by God in the mouth of the
prophets the Lord said You shall
persuade him and also Prevail go out and
do so lie through the mouths of the
prophets therefore look the Lord has put
a lying spirit in the mouth of the these
prophets of yours and the Lord has
declared disaster against you so so the
Bible according to them is saying God
the Lord put a lying spirit in the mouth
of their prophets and destroyed a people
we as Muslims never would agree with
something like this Allah does not lie
Allah does not deceive and he does not
allow Muslims to lie or deceive the is
not an Islamic concept what about um
this passage in the New Testament where
Paul is saying if I'm paraphrasing the
the verse where he's saying if by if by
if my Lie by gaining people to come to
the truth if my Lie by lying I'm able to
do that I'm justified by God that is
true right you know this passage yes of
course I mean we find in the New
Testament where Paul justifies lying in
trying to promote his beliefs this would
be te now that would be say so this is
the hocy try to but that's not in the
Quran yeah alhamdulillah that's not in
the Sunnah that's not in Islam that is
something that Paul and the Shia can
deal with Paul and the Shia so uh
wrapping up here with this part this is
very important uh because Muslims some
Muslims fell into the to the idea that
okay they have to defend theia meaning
that like these things that we mentioned
with um trying to reconcile between
people with the wife example they think
this this is TE but it's this we have
nothing to do with that and Islam have
nothing to do with each nothing to do
with that it's not in the Quran and
theith nothing not not at all okay a
Muslim is one who is truthful yeah and
this is why I think people need to be
educated before they talk about Islam
when you talk about things like the
temporary marriage this was a
pre-islamic practice that was condemned
in the Quran when the ayat about getting
married nikah came and who you can have
relations with and it was condemned in
clear authentic like that in the of IM
Muslim that is narrated by people from
that
where forbid the practice of mut and
even the in Muslim where he says he
forbid till the day of judgment Allah it
used to be allowed in the earlier days
it was a p pre-islamic practice through
three stages it was forbidden in
different ways just like alcohol there
were stages to it and then the prophet
peace be upon him said the practice of
temporary marriage is forbidden by Allah
until the day of judgment so if somebody
tries to bring these things they need to
be educated these are not Islamic
practices even if some sects some
Breakaway groups may practice them
they're not allowed in Islam all right
thank you we covered a lot here
appreciate the time again Eddie it's
always a pleasure seeing you
alhamdulillah I'm a big fan so may Allah
bless you and protect you and keep you
on the right pathan you how's the dean
Center
coming alhamdulillah brothers and
sisters we've acquired the future Dean
Center property and we want to get the
mashid open first it's all coming along
we're installing the doors we can make
wo we've installed the carpets we have
many details to finish up but it's
coming along alhamdulillah we need a new
roof we need new windows and we need a
minbar that's right we need a minbar for
the musjid now if all of you want to be
a part of history and help build a house
of worship build a musjid for the sake
of Allah so Allah the Creator can build
for you a house in Jenna click the link
below donate right now may God alight
Allah reward all of
you we're in phase two aldah if you're
watching you got to support we're going
to start doing some dawa trainings out
there absolutely absolutely thank you
very much and thank you guys if you are
interested to learn more about what
we're talking about and the book that's
changing Minds hearts and giving you
purpose go to the website to get you one
for free the Deans show.com if you have
any questions
about what we talked about call us tell
them that I sent you 1 1800 662 Islam
66247 62 we'll see you next time here in
the dean show until then peace be with
you assalam alaykum